april's playstation plus games have been
confirmed and season 2 details for halo
infinite could be on the horizon
sony has officially confirmed the
playstation plus lineup for april 2022
with three more games coming to the
service from very different genres first
up is spongebob squarepants battle for
bikini bottom rehydrated and speaking of
hydration slip some water
right now this game is a remake of the
2003 platformer of the same name minus
the rehydrated part while the remake was
received rather poorly at least you
don't have to pay money for it now the
second game is hood outlaws and legends
an online multiplayer game that could be
aptly compared to payday except with a
medieval setting matches feature two
teams of four working towards stealing
treasure not only do you have to worry
about the other team but there are also
computer controlled enemies to contend
with the third free game is slayed
aspire a deck building game with
overarching roguelike systems this game
even earned a 9 out of 10 from us at
gamespot these games will be available
on the 6th of april so you have until
then to claim the free games from march
in other playstation plus news sony
announced that persona 5 will be leaving
the playstation plus collection on may
11. the company confirmed that players
will have until this date to add persona
5 to their library in order to continue
to access it while they have an active
playstation plus subscription and this
is the perfect time to remind you that
whenever a game is up on playstation
plus always hit add to library even if
you don't want to play the game i've had
persona 5 added to my library a long
time ago and i have absolutely no
interest so if you hate spongebob who
cares add it to your library anyway it's
a free game you might change your mind
in the future or just want to have
something for your nephew to play when
he comes over just just add it it's a
free game and if you missed it yesterday
sony revealed its brand new playstation
plus subscription service which will
launch in june with three new tiers the
standard subscription will be rebranded
to playstation plus essential and will
cost sixty dollars per year while
playstation plus extra will cost fifteen
dollars per month or a hundred dollars
per year and will feature 400 ps4 and
ps5 games the most expensive tier is
called playstation plus premium and will
cost 18 per month or 120 dollars per
year and it will include up to
340 additional games to that 400 i
mentioned earlier as well as cloud
streaming support but in news that has
nothing to do with playstation plus head
creative at 343 industries joseph
stadton says fans can expect new details
on what's next really soon during an
interview with the washington post
statin said quote fans are really soon
going to be exposed to some really cool
stuff we've got going for season 2. it's
taken a little bit longer to get the
engine up to speed communications
flowing in the way that we want to but
the engine is cranking and i'm super
excited about the next year and beyond
staten later clarified on twitter that
the engine he was referring to is not
halo infinite's game engine he was
instead using the word as a metaphor for
the whole halo infinite live service
during the interviews statin also
stressed that 343 industries wants fans
to be able to rely on whatever new
information the team puts out in regards
to halo infinite it's a sentiment statin
has echoed before like in february when
a planned status update on the state of
the game's upcoming co-op and forge
modes was delayed so that the team could
finalize plans and share reliable
information let me know in the comments
if you're still playing halo infinite
and how often is it like every night or
are we talking like
you know fortnight on mondays call of
duty on on wednesdays and halo just on
sunday nights let me know
[Music]